Finn come on you promised what did I  promise I don't remember but a promise  is a promise grandma says calm down and  start your homework I need you to help  with the drawing do you remember them  who mom and dad you can remember don't  it's important I dream about them and  it's like they're right there then I  wake up and make on do you know where  we're going we're all along a journey  where am I my Island yours you don't  have an island it's called Finland  you abandoned me it wasn't like that it  was to me I wanted to start again what's  he doing it I don't know Finn he wants  to take you away from me here go take  this it'll carry you back up you were  supposed to be looking for me I am I  don't like this Finn I'm not playing  anymore I wanted to get your attention  you did there isn't much time  meet you had the crime scene